اكد وزير الخارجيه الايراني محمد جواد
ضريف اتفاق بلاده وفرنسا في موقفيهما حيال
الازمه الخليجيه وعلى ضروره حلها عبر
الحوار وبال الاساليب السلميه بدلا من
اللجوء الى الضغوط والحضر جاء ذلك خلال
زياره الوزير الايراني الى باريس في ختام
جوله اوروبيه كانت الازمه الخليجيه احد
محاور البحث
فيها
السلام عليكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش
فيما وراءه ما مدى استفاده ايران من
الازمه الراهنه في منطقه الخليج وما
التداعيات المحتمله لتفاقم هذه الازمه على
التوازنات
الاقليميه تؤكد قطر التزامها بالعمل في
الاطار الخليجي والعربي وتشدد على ان مجلس
التعاون الخليجي هو الملاذ الاخير
للاستقرار في المنطقه لكن كيف سيكون الحال
اذا ما طالت الازمه الراهنه يرد مراقبون
بالاشاره الى الاستفاده الايرانيه فبعد
الحصار ليس لقطر من منافذ الجيه الا عبر
ايران التي ابدت استعدادها لتزويد الدوحه
باحتياجاتها من المواد الغذائيه ويشير
مراقبون الى ان تعمق الازمه بتداعياتها
المحتمله يوفر فرصا لايران لتعزيز دورها
الاقليمي تقرير ناصر اي
طاهر من الخاسر ومن المستفيد هل حسب محاصر
قطر مالات ازمه افتعلها لم يعدم القطريون
منذ البدء موقفا اقليميا ودوليا متضامنا
مسانده وفي وجه حصار متعدد الاوجه ومطالب
تعجيزيه تنوعت لائحه الخيارات القطريه
فاوش كت على رسم مشهد خليجي جديد لم تخفي
ايران منذ تفجر الازمه تضامنها مع قطر
قالت ان المنطقه لا تتحمل مزيدا من
التصعيد وان الحوار لا العقوبات ولا
التهديد هو الحل الانسب كررها مسؤول
دبلوماسيتها في تنقلاته العربيه والغربيه
واحدثها فرنسا والمانيا واتفق في ذلك مع
مضيفيه الذين بدت لهم مطالب دول الحصار
موغله في
الاستفزاز تحركت اذا دبلوماسيه ايرانيه
نشطه
وترافقت وخطوات تعرض توفير رئه بديله
يتنفس منها الاقتصاد القطري ربما وضع ذلك
وغيره طهران في موقع المنافح عن الدوحه
ولعله نبه المحاصرين الى ان خطوتهم توشك
ان تحقق عكس ما رمت اليه ها هو الرئيس
الايراني مثلا يبدي لامير قطر في تهنئه
العيد حرصه على تنميه العلاقات الاقتصاديه
مع ما وصفها بالدوله الشقيقه
وها هو وزير الخارجيه القطري يؤكد ان
العلاقه مع الجاره ايران يجب ان تكون
بناءه صحيح ان قطر متميزه عن جيرانها في
مقاربه الشان الايراني لكنها لم تكن يوما
اقرب الى ايران من بعضهم فالامارات مثلا
تستحوذ على 80% من التبادلات التجاريه بين
طهران ودول مجلس التعاون اما قطر فصحيح
انها تتقاسم مع ايران حقل غاز وشريط
حدوديا بحريا لكن وجهات نظرهما تتباين
فيما يتعلق بنقل الطاقه واهم من ذلك ان
مواقفهما لا تلتقي البته من صراعات
اقليميه موقف قطر منها منسجم مع الموقف
الخليجي الاعم قد لا يجعل ذلك من ايران في
الوقت الراهن خيار قطر البديل الاول كما
هي تركيا مثلا لكن تحليلات ترى ان قطع
العلاقات مع قطر ومح ها ربما خلق فرصا
لايران على المدى الطويل من ذلك دفع قطر
وتركيا الى التقارب مع ايران بما يعزز
محورها الاقليمي من المراقبين في واشنطن
من ينبه الى ان الازمه الخليجيه قد تغير
الحسابات السياسيه في الشرق الاوسط فهي
برايهم تحدث صدعا في المعسكر المناوئ
لطهران في المنطقه لا سما وانها تهدد
بتفكك المنظومه الخليجيه اما المحللون
الايرانيون فنقر لاحدهم بان دول الحصار في
موقف صعب حاولت خلق جبهه موحده ضد قطر واذ
بها كما يقول تنشئ شرق اوسط يصفه بثنائي
القطب نرحب بضيفنا هنا في الاستديو
الدكتور محمد المختار الشنقيطي استاذ
الاخلاق السياسيه وتاريخ الاديان في جماعه
حمد بن خليفه في قطر على امل ان يلتحق بنا
ان شاء الله خلال هذه الحلقه ضيوف اخرين
نتمنى من الكويت ومن بيروت اهلا وسهلا بك
دكتور اهلا وسهلا هل يمكن ان نحدد الى اي
درجه استفادت ايران من الازمه الحاليه
اعتقد لنقيم استفاده ايران من الازمه
نحتاج ان ننظر الى الواقع قبيل الازمه
ايران كانت تعيش اسوا مراحل مراحلها في
علاقتها بالشعوب العربيه قبيل الازمه يعني
كانت سمعه ايران في الحضيض قبيل الازمه
بسبب الفظائع التي تورطت فيها في سوريا
وفي العراق ثم تدخلها في في اليمن وهذه
الازمه اعطت ايران فرصا هائله لاعاده
تاهيل نفسها اعاده بناء صورتها من جديد
ليس كدوله معتد لها امتدادات وتوغلت
ومطامع وانما دوله واقفه الى جانب الحق
وواقفه الى جانب المظلوم في ازمه خليجيه
خليجيه هذه ربما اكبر هديه استفادتها
ايران و حقيقه انا لو كنت مكان ل ارجاني
او او ظريف ربما اول ما ابدا به ان اشكر
السعوديه واشكر الدول المقاطعه على هذه
الهديه الاستراتيجيه الكبرى التي اهدتني
في هذه اللحظه و وهذا ربما ايضا يفسد
الحسابات التي كانت
ل الولايات المتحده التي ارادت ان تجعل
دول الخليج
واخرين صفا واحدا في مواجهه ايران خاصه
بعد القمه الخليجيه الامريكيه لا لا شك
انه كل ما قيل من من في قمه الرياض وكل
الحشود التي حشدت تلاشت في لمحه لمح البصر
بسبب هذه الازمه لانه بدلا من جبهه ضد
ايران تحولت الى لدينا معسكران ايران
تتصدر في احدهما او لها دور كبير في على
الاقل الى جانب تركيا صحيح ان القطريين
خيارهم كما قال التقرير خيارهم الاول هو
تركيا وقلبهم مع تركيا اكثر لكن الجغرافيا
تخدم ايران اكثر مما تخدم تركيا حتى في
الجانب الاقتصادي خطوط الا داد من تركيا
غيرها من ايران مثلا الثاني يعني وقوف
ايران يظن البعض انه مجرد مناكفه للسعوديه
ليس صحيحا حقيقه انه القدر الجغرافي جعل
ايران وقطر مرتبطتان باكبر حق الغاز في
العالم فهنالك منطق جغرافيا يفرض على
الدولتين مهما تكن خلافاتهم في الملفات
الاقليميه ان يظل هنالك نوع من مراعاه حسن
الجوار على الاقل للاستفاده من هذا الكنز
المشترك الذي جعلته الجغرافيا قدرا
لكلاهما
رحب بانضمام الدكتور نبيل خوري مسؤول
السابق في وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه معنا
من من بيروت دكتور ونحن نقلب درجه استفاده
ايران مما يجري هل يمكن القول ان احد اوجه
الاستفاده ايضا هذا التناغم بينها وبين
تركيا في ملف كبير
كالازار اظن بالطبع انه هذه الازمه
الخليجيه تقرب بعض الشيء من ايران وتركيا
على الاقل بالنسبه
للملف الخليجي ولكن اعتقد ان لهذا التقارب
حدود فما زالت هنالك اراء مختلفه
ومصالح مختلفه في سوريا
مثلا لذلك اعتقد انه هذا التقارب لم يذهب
بعيدا يعني الى نوع من التحالف
ولكن على كل حال بالنسبه لقطر فسيكون مفيد
ان يكون هنالك دولتان كبيرتان في المنطقه
على علاقات جيده مع قطر من حيث الاستفاده
الخاصه بايران تحديدا
دكتور هذه دوله كانت تصور على انها عنصر
عدم استقرار في المنطقه دوله مشاغبه دوله
ارهابيه في تعبيرات
بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين والغربيين الان
هي دوله تدعو الى التهدئه تدعو الى
الحوار هل هل هناك
اعاده صياغه ربما لصوره ايران من خلال هذه
الازمه بالنسبه
لامريكا يعني هذه الاداره هنالك اصوات
مختلفه داخلها وبالفعل هنالك البعض داخل
الاداره وبعض من
الدبلوماسيين
السابقين
مثل السفير بكرين مثلا يدعون الى علاقات
افضل مع ايران ويدعون الى استغلال هذه
الفرصه
ل التعاون دبلوماسيا ولو بشكل غير مباشر ل
تهدئه الوضع في
الخليج كذلك يدعون الى التعاون مع ايران
لتهدئه الوضع في اليمن ا برغم ذلك يعني
هنالك صعوبات سياسيه داخليه في
امريكا لا تشجع كثيرا على هذا
التعاون لذلك اعتقد انه حسب تطور الظروف
وحسب
قبول الدول الخليجيه ي وساطه يعني وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه يعمل جاهدا في هذه
الوساطه لانه يعتقد انه من مصلحه امريكا
ان يكون هنالك تفاهم
و وهذا التوت ليس من مصلحه امريكا ولكن اي
لحد الان يعني ليست هنالك نتائج ملموسه
لهذه الدبلوماسيه نعم عندما نرصد دكتور
شنقي الموقف الايراني من الازمه ايه دعوه
للتهدئه د دعوه الى الحوار ثم تطور الامر
الى انتقاد الشروط ثم الان ايه ايه هناك
تصاعد في اللهجه تجاه السعوديه تصريحات
الارجاني يقول صراحه السعوديه ليس لها هذا
الثقل حتى تستطيع ان تفرض كلمتها في
المنطقه هل هل هذا يمكن ان يحسب استفاده
معينه في علاقات ايران وهي تزيدها توترا
مع
السعوديه اعتقد انه كما تفضلتم طبعا هنالك
منحى تصاعدي
في التفاعل الايراني مع الازمه الخليجيه
ولكن من اول يوم اتضح ان ايران تاخذ
الموضوع بمحمل الجد ويكفي ان ظريف سافر
الى اسطنبول مع بدايه الازمه في نفس اليوم
الذي وق قعت فيه تفجيرات في ايران في في
في مواضع حساسه جدا بالنسبه للايرانيين
فهذا يعني اولويه الازمه واهميتها بالنسبه
للايرانيين وعموما انا اعتقد انه في نهايه
المطاف ايران دوله ذكيه وجدت ثغره في
معسكر كان يفترض ان ان يعمل معا ضدها وجبت
وجدت ثغره في الجبهه التي كان يفترض ان
تبنى ضدها فدخلت من تلك الثغره واستفادت
منها هي اصلا استفادت من سوء الاداء وضعف
الاداء الخلي اليي في الملفات التي كانت
تتصارع مع الخليجين فيها مث الملف السوري
مثلا كل الدعم الخليجي في النهايه انتهى
بانه ما ما استفاد الثوار السوريون كثيرا
منه استفاده نوعيه في الملف اليمني بعد 30
شهر ما استطاعوا يكسروا شوكه حلفاء ايران
في اليمن هي استفادت من ضعف الاداء ثم
وجدت فرصه اكبر حتى من هذا التراخي وضعف
الاداء وهو الشقاق الداخلي فقررت ان تدخل
منه بكل ثقلها طالما اشرت الى هذه الثغره
على الصعيد
الخليجي انضم الينا الان من الكويت
الدكتور فيصل ابو صليب استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت اهلا وسهلا بك
دكتور ابو صليب كنا نتحدث منذ بدايه هذا
البرنامج حول مدى استفاده ايران مما يجري
الان في الازمه الخليجيه وضيفنا الدكتور
شنقيطي يقول بان هي استفادت من هذه الثغره
في الصف الخليجي الى اي مدى تعتقد ان
الامر فعلا بهذا
الشكل
هو في الحقيقه بان النظام الاقليمي في في
منطقه الخليج غير مستقر يعني لم تتضح
هيكليه هذا النظام وبنيته منذ عام 91 الى
اليوم وبالتالي هناك متنافسين ولاعبين
رئيسيين في في هذا النظام الاقليمي لا
يمكن لاي دوله منافسه في المنطقه ان تشاهد
دوله اخرى وهي تحاول ان تفرض السيط
على المنطقه دون ان تتدخل لذلك الموقف
الايراني موقف متوقع عندما راى بان
السعوديه يزيد نفوذها في المنطقه خصوصا
بعد التغيرات التي حدثت بعد زياره ترامب
الى الى المنطقه لذلك انا اعتقد بان ايران
دائما تنتهز مثل هذه الفرص لتحقيق المصلحه
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لايران حدث هذا
الامر الحقيقه بعد الغزو العراقي للكويت
على الرغم من ان علاقات الكويت لم تكن
علاقات جيده مع ايران خلال الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه لكن خلال الغزو العراقي انتهجت
ايران موقفا ايجابيا من الغزو العراقي
وبالتالي هي استغلت الفرصه حينها لتحقيق
خطوه ايجابيه بالنسبه للمصلحه
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه ونفس هذا الموقف
الان يتكرر مع الازمه الخليجيه ايران
تحاول ان تنتهز الفرص وهي غالبا ما تنجح
في مثل هذا الامر نجحت في 90 91 في الغزو
العراقي نجحت ايضا في 2003 والحرب
الامريكيه على العراق وانتهزت هذه
التغيرات لصالحها وايضا الان تريد تكرار
مثل هذا الامر بتحقيق المصلحه
الاستراتيجيه لجانب ايران بمحاوله ان يكون
لها نفوذ داخل دوله في في منظومه مجلس
التعاون وهي وهي قطر ولا شك بان مثل هذه
المقاطعه على قطر وتصريح وزير الخارجيه
القطري بان لا يوجد منفذ جو
الا عبر ايران بالتاكيد هناك استفاده
حقيقيه من الموقع الجغرافي بالنسبه لايران
من مثل هذه الازمه نعم هناك ايضا مساله
مهمه سنناقشها بعد الفاصل هي التي تتعلق
بالتداعيات المحتمله لتفاقم الازمه
الخليجيه على التوازنات الاقليميه على
الاقل كما كانت تبدو قبل هذه الازمه
لنعود
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نتناول فيها مدى استفاده ايران من الازمه
الخليج والتداعيات المحتمله لاستمرارها
دكتور شنقيطي ربما من اكثر الاطراف تضررا
هو هيكل مجلس التعاون الخليجي الذي
للتذكير انشئ عام 81 بالاساس لتكوين نوع
من جدار الصد امام الثوره الاسلاميه انذاك
التي كانت في بداياتها الان هذا الهيكل
يتصدع ما تاثير ذلك من خلال هذه الازمه
انا اعتقد انه للاسف مجلس التعاون الخليجي
يعيش و حالاته في عهد الملك سلمان
والطريقه التي تتعامل بها السعوديه الان
مع المجلس ربما السعوديه لا تزال تظن ان
المجلس هو كما كان الحال في الثمانينات
والتسعينات يعني هو مجلس حول السعوديه
ودول تسير في الفلك السعودي بينما في
حقيقه الامر طرا كثير من الامور بعد ذلك
بدات هذه الدول تبني نوع من الهويه
السياسيه المستقله عن القرار السياسي
السعودي الكويت اصبحت تعيش يعني في قرار
مستقل تريد ان تعمل توازن ربما اخذت
العبره من الغزو العراقي فقررت ان ان تكون
متوازنه في علاقتها بين السعوديه والعراق
وايران عمان اصلا غردت خرج السرب من زمان
وعلاقتها ليست جيده لا بالسعوديه ولا
بالامارات فعمل بهذه الازمه اصبح مجلس
التعاون منشط شطرين ثلاث دول في جانب
وثلاث دول في جانب اخر والذين يظنون انهم
طبعا سيدون قطر بمجرد انه خلاص سنخرج لكم
مجلس تعون هذا معناه ببساطه و وهذا غير
وارد اصلا اذا ثلاثه ضد ثلاثه بالضبط ليس
وارد حتى واحد مقابل خم لانه نظام المجلس
قراراته بالاجماع اصلا هذا ليس واردا فاذا
كان عندنا حاله الانشطار اي سعي لهذا
المساء معناها شهاده وفاه لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي نعم دكتور خوري الولايات المتحده
وهي ترى
حلفائها هكذا يتناثر
برايك ما الذي يمكن ان تقوم به ان كان ما
يمكن ان كان يوجد اصلا ما يمكن القيام به
الان
اعتقد انه اولا الدبلوماسيه التي يقوم
بها وزير الخارجيه ترسن
جيده قد يكون من الجيد ايضا ان بعض
الاشخاص في
الاداره المقربين
من القياده السعوديه ان يحاولوا معهم اكثر
واكثر لتطريه موا قفهم
ا يعني هنالك اصوات كما قلت مختلفه في
امريكا
و هنا كما نعلم ان دونالد ترامب تسرع في
بادئ الامر
بموافقته على المواقف السعوديه
باتهامات لقطر ومن ثم تم تذكيره من قبل
وزير الدفاع ووزير الخارجيه بمصالح امريكا
المرتبطه بقطر وخاصه وجود قاعده القياده
المركزيه في
عديد ولكن هنا هناك اصوات وخاصه من
الاصوات المسانده لاسرائيل وقد كتب دينس
راس مؤخرا يقول ربما حان الوقت لامريكا ان
تنقل قاعدتها خارج قطر هذه الاصوات يجب ان
تجابه من قبل اصوات اخرى في امريكا لذلك
اعتقد انه هذه مرحله على عده طبقات يعني
هنالك الطبقه الرسميه والدبلوماسيه
الرسميه ولكن هنالك ايضا مراكز الابحاث
وهنالك الاشخاص المؤثرين في السياسه
وخاصه امثال دانس راس
وبعكسه هنالك اصوات سفير بكرين وغيره
وبالنهايه هؤلاء سيكون لهم دور يلعبوه على
الاداره الامر امريكيه
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي ارشاد يعني واعطاء النصح لان
ربما هذا هذا
الخط يعني منطق القوه ومنطق السيطره
والهيمنه وهذا التنافس على قياده مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ليس في مصلحه احد واعتقد
يعني انه كلما كانت هنالك اصوات تدعو الى
التهد ولا تنتقد لا هذا الطرف ولا ذاك
وهذا ينطبق على امريكا كما ينطبق على على
ايران اعتقد انه
بالنهايه ستخرج هذه
الازمه من عنق الزجاجه لانها
بالنهايه تنافس على على القوه والسيطره
وليست
بالفعل تغيير مناهج سياسيه لانه اعتقد انه
هذه هذه هي اعذار اكثر مما هي اسباب
حقيقيه بالنهايه مصالح قطر ومصالح
السعوديه لا تختلف كثيرا وان اختلفت
احيانا توجهاتهم في السياسه الخارجيه وصوت
قطر يختلف ولكنه اعتقد انه صوت مهم برهن
عن نفسه في الماضي بانه صوت مهم وكانت
واشنطن تقتنع
[موسيقى]
بالدبلوماسيين تحرص دول الخليج على الحفاظ
على هذا الصوت وليس خفته نعم هناك ايضا
مفارقه دكتور ابو صليب في في الفتره
الماضيه كان هناك تناغم كبير بين قطر
والسعوديه خاصه بعد زياره الملك سلمان الى
الدوحه البعض حتى كان يلوم قطر انها عادت
مره اخرى تحت العباءه السعوديه بعد حكم
الشيخ حمد المختلف عن عن ابنه في هذه
النقطه على الاقل الان جاءت هذه الازمه
وكانها كسرت مره
اخرى هذه العلاقه مع الشقيق الاكبر
وبالتالي هل من السهل راب هذا الصدع الذي
يبدو انه يزداد مع
الايام هو لا شك بان السعوديه لم تكن
مرتاحه من سياسه قطر الخارجيه منذ 95 96
لكن السعوديه حينها في فتره التسعينيات لم
تكن ظروف مهيئه لمواجهه مثل هذه التغيرات
التي تحدث في المنطقه خصوصا بعد نتائج
وتبعات عمليه تحرير الكويت على الاقتصاد
السعودي
وايضا زياده العمليات التخريبيه داخل
السعوديه بعد 91 لذلك السعوديه في فتره
التسعينيات وصولا الى 2001 احداث 11
سبتمبر
وزياده الضغط الدولي حتى حينها على
السعوديه لذلك الظروف وقتها لم تكن مهيئه
لمثل هذا التحرك وصولا الى اداره اوباما
التي اعتقد بانها كانت تنظر الى قطر بانها
تشكل نقطه رئيسيه ومحورا رئيسيا في
المنطقه لحل الازمات وخصوصا مبدا اوباما
المتعلق بالتقارب مع ايران وفتح باب
الحوار مع مع ايران لذلك اداره اوباما
كانت تنظر الى السعوديه بانها تشكل مشكله
اكبر من انها تشكل حلا لكن مع وصول اداره
ترامب انا اعتقد بان مثل هذه الظروف تحولت
لصالح السعوديه مره اخرى وبالتالي وجدت
السعوديه بان هذه فرصه لمحاوله ان صح
التعبير تعديل مره اخرى موازين القوى
لصالحها في المنطقه وتصفيه كل الحسابات
القديمه مع مع قطر وايضا في الفتره
الماضيه كانت في حرب اليمن السعوديه تحتاج
الى دعم قطر خصوصا دعم قطر الاعلامي من
خلال قناه الجزيره التي ايدت بشكل كبير
عمليه عاصفه الحزم وكانت صوتا اعلامي
مؤيدا لهذه العمليه السعوديه الخليجيه في
اليمن لكن الان تغيرت مثل هذه الظروف
لصالح مره اخرى محاوله اعاده اعاده تشكيل
موازين القوى في المنطقه لصالح السعوديه
لكن النقطه الرئيسيه انا اعتقد بان النظام
الاقليمي مثل ما قلت في البدايه النظام
الاقليمي الخليجي وفي منطقه الجزيره
العربيه نظام يقوم على تعدد الاقطاب لا
يمكن لطرف واحد ان يحقق الهيمنه الكامله
على هذه المنطقه لذ هذه هذه هذه العله
الرئيسيه في هذه المنطقه وهذا السبب
الرئيسي وراء تكرار مثل هذه الازمات
المتكرره في في المنطقه لكن مره اخرى
الحقيقه بان هذه الازمه ان ان ان كان هناك
نتائج من هذه الازمه انا اعتقد بان قطر
مختلفه عن بقيه الدول الاخرى يعني عندما
قررت الدول العربيه مثلا مقاطعه مصر بعد
اتفاقيات كام ديفيد مصر دوله كبيره في
النظام الاقليمي لذلك اتجهت الى الى
افريقيا مثلا المحيط الافريقي لمحاوله
تعويض النقص او حتى العراق بعد 91 عندما
حاولت الدول الخليجيه عزل العراق لم تحقق
نتائج كبيره لكن قطر دوله صغيره محيطها
الاقليمي هو المحيط الخليجي لذلك انا
اعتقد بان القواسم المشتركه بين قطر
والسعوديه اكبر من القواسم المشتركه بين
بين قطر وايران لذلك قطر تدرك بان المحيط
الاقليمي نظام الاقليم الخليجي مجلس
التعاون هو الخيار الاستراتيجي بالنسبه
لها لذلك هذه صعوبه صعوبه التعامل مع هذه
الازمه من جانب قطر شكرا لك الدكتور فيصل
ابوصليب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من بيروت الدكتور
نبيل خوري المسؤول السابق في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وللضيف هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور محمد مختار الشنقيطي
استاذ الاخلاق السياسيه وتاريخ الاديان في
جامعه حمد بن خليفه في قطر في امان
الله يعطيك العافيه يا سيدي
شكرا